today we begin talking about our
finances right and how we can manage
them better
this new year kendall got to speak with
uh money coach
lisa chastain for more check it out
over to a new year and starting fresh
and there are some things they can do
when it comes to planning for the new
year financially
and it really begins with understanding
what's happened already for so many of
us what 2020 has taught us is to expect
the unexpected
and normally new year's resolution
resolutions focus on money
and health and creating these bigger
goals and this year my advice is to keep
it simple
the best way to do that is just look at
what's working in your life
today what's not working in your life
and audit some of those things so that
you can think about what you would
change given that you can't control so
much and your finances will work
around that but choose one thing one
thing that you think
isn't working in your life and then
create a smaller goal to go with that
and
realign your finances around that one
goal you know it's interesting
you talk about understanding the things
we can't control
and it really does at the end of the day
come down to a mindset and that's the
second thing you wanted to talk about
absolutely again new year's resolutions
we think about these big things that we
want to change in our life and
ultimately what we learned in 2020 is
that we can't control a lot but we can
control the way that we react
the way that we respond and the way that
we choose to respond to circumstances in
our lives and money is one of those
things that causes a lot of emotional
reaction
so what i would say is that this is the
best year moving into 2021
where especially in las vegas resources
might be limited
so instead let's work on our mindset
let's work on our mindset around money
why do we make the choices that we make
how we can create a positive
loving relationship with money that
doesn't have to cost a lot
and finally you talk about the three
ways we invest
what are those right well in the money
world a lot of people talk about
investing in the stock market
we're using our finances our financial
resources to invest and what to do
and what not to do again this doesn't
have to cost a lot but i say there are
three ways we invest
we invest with our time we invest with
people in our life
and we invest with money so rather than
focusing on all the great things that
you want to do with your money this year
why don't we focus on the things that
are working and not working in our
relationships
and are working in our relationship with
time or aren't working in our
relationship with time
if you look at your life that way
thinking about 2021
you could have an amazing year by
learning how to invest in yourself
get the get new education get new tools
in your tool
belt and work on relationships work on
improving relationships
and work on your relationship with time
those three things combine
you can have a stellar year in 2021 that
doesn't have to cost a lot
lisa as always really fun talking to you
and i wish you the very
best for 2021 we'll be talking to you a
lot thank you kendall you too